Ben
[Müzik]
bugün burada Buraya Türk milli takımının
antrenman kampından çıkıp geldim ve
gelirken Kendime şunu söyledim Burada
olmalıyım Çünkü burada olmamın sebebi
ile benim şu anda Türk milli takımını
antrenman yaptırmak sebebim hemen hemen
aynı sebep Bizler birer bütün parçasıyız
ve birbirimiz için çalışıyoruz bunu
unutmamak gerekiyor Şu her şey
17 yaşında bir kız çocuğunun ailesiyle
beraber yazın olimpiyat oyunlarında
artistik yüzmeyi O zamanki adıyla
senkronize yüzmeyi halk dilinde daha çok
su böylesi olarak bilinen branşı
seyretmesi ile başladı ve her şey o kız
çocuğunun kararlılığı ile başladı
Sonra başladığım ilk üç yıl Türkiye
şampiyonu oldum arkasından dördüncü yıl
milli takıma seçildim ve altı yılında
Avrupa Şampiyonası'nda finale kalan ilk
Türk takımının en başarılı sporcusu
olarak
ülkemi temsil ettim tabii ki burada
başta Atatürk olmak üzere ilham aldığım
birçok kişi oldu E bugün konumuz çıkış
ben kendi çıkışımı buradaki çıkışımı
kapı metaforu ile size anlatmak
istiyorum
Evet Ee hayatında kaç tane kapı açıldı
Hangi kapılardan dışarı çıktım hangi
kapılar Açık mamla aslında başka
kapıların içerisinden yeni dünyalara
girdim bunu anlatacağım hikayemi
anlatırken Sizlerin de benim girdiğim
kapıları belki dikkat etmenizi belki
Sayfanızı isteyeceğim
mi Evet bugün burada dünya şampiyonu
olmuş bir sporcu olarak değil yeni dünya
şampiyonları yetiştirmek için bu Ülke
topraklarında emek veren hiç durmadan
çalışan 20 yıllık eski bir milli sporcu
ve aynı zamanda 12 yıllık bir milli
takım antrenörü olarak bulunuyorum
2013 yılında
da en son katıldım üniversite at
üniversite Olimpiyatları 2012 senesi
Londra olimpiyatları'ndan hemen sonra
gerçekleşti ve üniversite
olimpiyatlarından sonra artık jübilemi
yaptım düşünüyordum acaba daha fazla şey
verebilir miyim bu spora devam etmeli
miyim diye BV tam o noktada
Ben kendime Şu soruyu sordum
çocukluğundan beri yaptığım bir iş emek
verdiğin inandığın doğrularım var Eğer
Sence bir şey yapmak istiyorsan bu
soruyu kendine sorar mıydın artık
sporculuk Hayatını tıkanmıştı be
gerçekten
bu ülkede bu ülkede birşeyleri nereye
gitmesi için birilerini sorumluluk
alması gerekiyor Bunu sadece kendi
branşınız olarak değerlendirmeye elim
bugün hoşumuza gitmeyen bugün bu işin
böyle değil başka bir yöntemi var diyen
her kim varsa
kendisi yapmaya bugünden başlamalı Çünkü
eleştirmek değil bir yol açmak çok
önemli Ne demişler Ya bir yol bul ya bir
yol aç ya da yoldan çekip Dolayısıyla
ben bu motorlarla
Bu karar verdim 2013 senesinde spor
hayatımı sonlandırdım Tabiki spor
kariyerimde sayısız dünya şampiyonaları
tecrübesi Avrupa şampiyonları tecrübesi
olimpiyat elemeleri Londra Üniversitesi
gidebileceğim bütün müsabakalarda
ülkemizi gururla temsil ettim onur
duyuyorum Tabii ki bundan ek olarak
devam ediyorum 2013 yılında aile önünde
büklüm eyle
ne altını destekleyen Maddi manevi bütün
imkanlar kayboldu ne yapabilirim diye
düşünüyordum bu zamana kadar gerçekten
buraya Hani acı dolu belki zor anları
anlatmaya gelmedim Ama şunu da söylemek
istedim geçtiğimiz yolları Ne kadar zor
olduğu belki yaşarken çok zor Evet ama
dönüp baktığınızda bu zorluğu aşmış
olmak oralardan o dikenli yollardan
geçmiş olmak sizi Bulunduğunuz konumdan
birkaç kademe daha yukarıda olmak ve
tecrübeye sahip olmak gibi paha
biçilemez özellikler kazandırıyor
mi Evet ailem bölünmüştü tam o dönemde
spor hayatımı sonlandırdım ve dedim Ne
yapabilirim Elimden Tutan tek şey Emek
verdiğim işim kaç uykusuz Sabah kaç
nefessiz gece kaç
gitmediğim görüşmediğim arkadaşlarım
uzak kaldım belki dışarıda devam eden
hayattı ve ben bütün bu alın terimi aynı
Havuzun içerisinde toplayan o su
damlalarına geri döndüm dedim ki ben bu
işe kendim için değil gelecek nesiller
için başkalarına çıkış olmak için yapmak
zorundayım Benim hayata giriş amacım bu
insanlara Dokunma aynı Bunu bir daha
gibi düşünün nasılki bir Dağcı en tepeye
en zirveye çıktığında var Ancak
arkasından gelenlerin elinden tutup
gitti
Ve kendimi de aynı öyle tasvir ettim ve
dolayısıyla tırmanmaya başladım Evet
sonra
bir gün Marmara Üniversitesi spor
bilimleri fakültesinde okuyorum spor
hayatım
başarı dolu spor hayatına içerisinde
söylüyorum Çünkü vaz geçmek çok zor oldu
devam ediyor ve ben Marmara
üniversitesi'de kanalın kapısını çaldım
Çünkü böyle olmuyor annemin hastalıkları
nüksetti nasıl ki anlatmam lazım bir
haftada belki on acil servis biz annemle
beraber Bir kapıdan çıktık ve karşımıza
nelerin geleceğini habersiz bir şekilde
Bu Hayat Yolunda devam ediyorduk
ve mavi Üniversitesi spor bilimleri
fakültesi dekanının kapısını çaldım ve
ben bu okuldaki havuzlarda kendi
branşında öğretmek istiyorum 20 yaşında
bir genç kızdan bahsediyoruz bu henüz
bırakmış bu havuzlarda kendi bilime ve
Hayat Hakkında kendi bildiklerimi kendi
mesleğimle anlatmak istiyorum Kulaç
atmak üzerine
hayatta bir şekilde yeni adımlar atmakla
aynı şeyi yaşadığımızı aslında en yeni
nesillere aktarmak istiyorum kolay
olmadı bu konuşmanın arkasından Ben
okuldan çıktım mavi Anadolu Hisarı
Kadıköy dolmuşları vardır İstanbul'da
bindim uzun bir yoldur o yanımda bir kız
bir zahmet tacı var hiç unutmuyorum
bu burada cebimde Ben Türk bayraklı
boneyi taşırdım Çünkü Nereye gideceğim
nerede kalacağım ne yapacağım her
şekilde Anlamana gitmem gerekiyor ve
antrenmanda Türk bayraklı abonelik yoksa
Hoca takımı almaz her borcunun belli bir
sayıda vardır O zaman imkanlarımız
şimdiki gibi değil Onu kaybetmemek teki
havlu bulundurmaya bulunur terlik
Bulunur o bulunmaz
bu kafasına bir prenses tacı var Sports
for diyorum hala sporcu değil beş
yaşında bir kızdır
şu an milli sporcu Evet
Ben dedim ki sana prenses olmayı
öğretmeni ister misin Çünkü ben pek
modları inanmam toplumun Bir de bitmiş
oldu tutma pişmiş oldu o Prenses
masalları inanmam Ben geleneksel olan
Böyle Gelmiş Böyle Gider denilen benim
yaşadığım buydu Sen de bunu yaşayacağım
diye yola çıkan hiçbir hikaye inanmam
buradaki herkes çok farklı ve herkesin
aynı durumları içerisinde bile bulursa
kendi potansiyellerini bana unutmamanız
istiyorum siz herkesten farklısınız bunu
bilmenin önemi Yanılmaz büyük
Fatiha sonra öğreteyim dedim belki dedim
prenses olmaz belki Savaşçı bir kadın
olursun zırhın olur tarafında da tabi
anlamadı de Bim'den Türk bayraklı bana
mı çıkardım verdim öğretmeni ister misin
dedim o ilk borcu
O öyle başladım mm
312 yılın 13 yılında o zaman Ülkemize
gelen bir takım antrenörü bütün klipleri
geziyor Kendisi çok başarılı bir
russian-turkish ekibin antrenörü
ve Beni yardımcı antrenör olarak asistan
coach olarak davet ediyor takıma Onunla
beraber yeni sistemler düzenliyoruz
Onunla beraber yeni antrenman teknikleri
öğretiyoruz herkese hiç durmadan
çalışıyorum bazen Ondan bazen değil Her
zaman ondan da çok çalışıyorum
mi Evet sonra
2014-15 senesinde takımımız Avrupa'da ve
dünyada final kalıyor ve bütün dünyaya
Aslında Türklerin Bu sporda iyi olduğunu
göstermeye başlıyoruz yeni eğitim
sistemleri başlıyor sporda yeni bir
jenerasyon başlıyor pilotsuz gelişim
dönüşümle aynı şeydir siz bana bir şey
söylersiniz Ben de bir şey söyledim
Aklımdaki bilgiler yenilerim dönüştürüp
ve gelişim böyle başlar
devam edeceğim Bu yoldan ilerledik
2015 senesinde Fenerbahçe baş antrenör
olarak teklif aldım Ömer başka şampiyon
olarak hala şu anda görev yapıyorum 2017
senesinde yeni eğitim tekniklerini
Türkiye'ye getirmek ile alakalı yüzmede
ve artistik yüzmede Çünkü yüzme
federasyonu eğitim komitesi Başkanı
olarak görevime devam ettim 2021 yılında
yani geçtiğimiz yıl bütün branşın
sorumluluğu üstüme aldım ve çoğu anda bu
branşta yüzüne federasyondaki tek
sorumluyum
bu hikayeler olurken Aslında
gerçekten çıkılması çok zor kapılardan
da çıktım ve az önce çaldığım kapıyı
size söyledim
Gerçekten çok kolay olmadı ha bunlar
olurken başka şeyler olmadı mı Tabii ki
oğlu
Ben eminim gelecek nesiller bizlerden
daha multidisipliner şeyler yapacaklar
benim branşım yüzmenin ara da yüzmenin
cimnastiğin dansın Balenin ve apartmanda
bir boksör kadar dayanıklı olmanın bir
yandan da bir kuğu gibi idari formanın
birleşiminden oluşuyor bunu yaparken
yıllarca pilates yoga vee fitness
eğitmenliği yaptım bana destek
olabileceğine İnandığım bütün spor dalı
ile alakalı ciddi eğitimler aldım belki
Hani bu eğitimlere benim çok zorlasada
Ve arkasından bir yandan da Türkiye'de
ilkleri gerçekleştirmeye başladım
bunlardan bir tanesi
Asis Sualtı şovları ydı onun şimdi açık
göstermek istiyorum Bu arada
bu eklemek istedim ki söyle bu önümde
yürüyen sporcu
onu dünya şampiyonası Özel bir davet
aldı bu Türk tarihinde bir ilktir Henüz
daha 15 yaşında bu Geçtiğimiz ay
gittiğimiz Paris yufkasından
Evet bu Buradan çıkıp geldim Kaptan
yanımda Dünyanın en ünlü programı
anahtarı ermakova var o projeyi yazdım
ve kabul ettirmek gerçekten çok zor
bazen zor olabilir bazen gerçekten ben
insanları yaptığınız işe inandırıp önce
sizin saygı duymamız gerekiyor Fakat
inandırıp o rüzgarla bir şeyleri kabul
ettirmek zor oluyor olabilir ama sizin
inanmanız kendi yaptığınız şeye saygı
göstermeniz çok önemli
bu
daha sonra burada Bakın bu olimpiyat
elemelerine giderken kalkıp da o
zamanlar telefonlar şimdi kadar iyi
değil çekilmiş Omuzumda 8 farklı yerde
yırtık var doktor bana sen bu kolla
denize taş bile atamazsın Acil A Spor
bırakman gerekiyor dedi
inanamadım yani böyle bir şey olamaz
diye ve farklı tedavi yöntemleri denedim
burada o yüzden kolum sargıda ama
kapatayım bir yandan da gitmiyorum yani
çektiğim o zaman fiziksel acıyı ruhsal
acı daha da büyük Tabii ki he ve
ya ben bu kola 4 müsabakaya daha
katıldım bu demek değil ki kendime zarar
veriyorum Hayır İngilizlerin bir lafı
vardır isteriz abi Elzem ederler Eğer
bir şey olacaksa onun Bu yolu var bir
yolu bulunur ve ben şu sözü de söylemek
istiyorum bana çok rehber oldu sözsüz
maddi Beynimiz özüdür
bu hayatta
Sen kaybetmekten korkmayan tek Kahraman
masal kahramanı kendi hikayesini
yazandır dar Siz kendi hikayenizi
yazarsanız Siz kendi inandığımız yolda
yürürseniz 1000 kişide 1 milyon kişi de
o yolun yanlış olduğunu söylese bile
mantıksız olduğunu söylese bile
vazgeçmez Seniz o zaman Siz kendi
hikayenin kahramanı olursunuz
Dolayısıyla Ben bir yolunu bulmuştu
Ama bu Londra olimpiyat elemelerinde
değil yukarıdan Havuzun üstünden
çekilmiş bir fotoğraf hala Kolum sakat
Ama bu yine Londra olimpiyat
elemelerinde
Ama bu benim
gerçekleştirdim ilk Sualtı konseptinde
Soğanlı konsepti Sualtı sirkin den gelen
bir fotoğraf
2012 yılında Türkiye'de yeni akvaryumlar
açılmaya başladı ve bu akvaryumlar
Dediler ki biz daha önce İngilizce kitle
çalışıyorduk işte arada Fransızlarda
geliyordu böyle böyle bir şeyler
yapıyorlar Çünkü de bu sporun vardı
Haberimiz Yok
Ha bu arada Türkiye'de bu sporun
varlığını haberi olmadı Tabii ki normal
bir şey Çünkü ben dünya şampiyonasına
gittiğimde ona sorulan soru şuydu
Türkler mayo girebiliyor mu
ama inanın bu soruyu Bu sorunun yanında
hiçbir şey
evet var dedim Biz yapabiliyoruz Tabii
ki de bunu
bir izleyeyim dedim yani Nedir bu su 62
Çünkü biz bütün olayı suyun üstünde
gerçekleştiriyoruz ne kadar dik ne kadar
yüksek ne kadar çok hızlı ettiğimizde
alakalı her şey daha sonra
baktım dinlediğim yani kafadan bir
cesaretle E ben bunu kesin yaparım
demedim baktım neler yapmışlar
mi Evet bu arada bu da küçük bir balık
var ama bu akvaryum köpek balıkları
vardı balık adamlar tarafından
durduruluyor Hadi elektrikli sopalarla
bir köpek balıklarıyla beraber
bu gösteri yaptık yine çok sevdiğim bir
şey diyeceğim burada
şans cesareti olanın yanındadır derler
latinceden çevresi bu yani Şans diye bir
şey yoktur
cesaret vardır ve hayat deneyenler indir
korkmayanların dır ben bu işe giderken
milli takımı topladım hepsini bu iş
yapılırken on gün boyunca her gün ona
haberler deydik daha sonra bu bitti
etkisi devam etti hala her gün
televizyon dayız nasıl yapıyoruz ki
sabah programları çekime geliyor bir
sürü şeyler gerçekleşiyor Bu arada
sadece bir çıkış olmaktan bahsederken
Evet arkadaşlar Ya aslında kendi
çıkışımız bulmak önemli ama
Biz başkalarına çıkış olmak daha önemli
bence
bu Çünkü ben kendi sporcu ama biraz
çıkış olmayı öğretiyorum hep ve eğer ben
başka takım arkadaşıma çıkış olmasaydım
bu ekibi oraya toplayamaz dım Onlar
benim takım arkadaşlarım bana o kadar
güveniyorlar o kadar destekliyorlar ki
şu an hala ona yardımcı antrenörlük
yapıyorlar benim ekibim deler Ben de
çalışıyorlar Nezaket değil iletişim ve
başlatma çıkış olmak el vermek bizi de
iyileştirecek olan şey bu devam ediyoruz
luca bu seyrettim göstereyim Sualtı
konseptiyle üstünde Yaptığımız her şeyi
suyun altına taşı Tıp bütün pozisyonları
Çünkü bir su tankının içindeyiz ve
akvaryumun içinde bizi seyirci buradan
görecek
şunu da çoğu düşünmedim ama şunu dediler
bunu yapıyorlar zaten İngiltere'de bir
sürü artistik gücü var bunu yaparlar
Rusya'da var gelir yaparlar ama
yapmadılar bunu düşünmem işler
yaptıkları göstereyim bunu alakası yok
bu ve sonra bu gösteriden sonra Las
Vegas Trump içten başka bir akvaryum
teklifi geldi Burada yine soğan 2
konseptiyle sanki uçuyoruz olarak
yaptığımız gösterdi birkaç parçası abone
ol
Ya ben bu kızı zamanda size
kendime güvenerek inanarak ve o kapıları
korkmadan çalarak mücadele ettiğim
şeylerden hızlıca bahsetmeye çalıştım
şunu söylemek istiyorum siz Eğer bir
kapıyı açar çalarsanız kuvvetli bir
şekil o kapasite açılır ama Pes etmeyin
vazgeçmeyin ve başka insanları el
vermeye zirvede bile olsanız aşağıda
olsanız onları da tutup yanında çekmeye
asla vazgeçmeyin Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]